you know there are people in the world
who like to have sex
with horses they take said horse excite
said horse this was a child's show
before you got here children go to sleep
yeah hi i'm gq's mark anthony green by
day i'm a writer for the magazine and by
night when i'm not re-watching coming to
america and chasing girls that are
completely out of my league
i'm hanging out at our barber shop at
barclays center getting haircuts and
talking with interesting people
hopefully they don't pick up my hair too
bad
hey hey hey hey i got my man morgan with
me
hey man morgan so man other than you
know pulling for uh
holding for my sad nets yeah well since
we're at barclays
pulling for those incredible
hard-working second best a for effort
nets
that is my boys what are you working on
now i was a big fan of albert hitchcock
growing up
yeah birds scared the [ __ ] out of those
yeah i always wanted to make one of
those weird twisted dark shows
yeah and so now we're making one for
showtime called seven deadly sins okay
there's an episode about wrath there's
one about greed one about
gluttony you didn't want to cast me and
rihanna for the lust one
you guys would have been good in that i
think i lost that email or something my
agent
i've got to get my agent there's a story
about this company called uh erotic
exotics
you know there are people in the world
who like to have sex
with uh with horses i'm from kansas city
yeah that's like promising
but what do you do you know when
suddenly there's not a horse around
well thank goodness there's a company
like exotic erotics they
take said horse yeah um excite said
horse
insert device over said horse's ballast
with a mold
and then make basically a giant horse
dildo to send to you
in the comfort of your own home this was
a child's show before you got here
that's right
you are really children go go to sleep
uh you grew up a sixers fan i grew up a
doctor jfan
had the poster on my wall did you try
the afro out i
you know as much as i could you know
being a pale kid in west virginia
see i grew up in the allen iverson
sixers era
i wanted cornrows and was your mom down
for that my mother was the one she was
the voice of reason
cornrow blocked my cornrows she corn
blocked you she corn blocked me
rich how would you classify morgan's
mustache today a mistake
no i'm super into it is that a spoon is
that what that's called
that's a classic handlebar full manchu
would be longer
it's kind of like a handlebar it'll go
longer but it it
it comes out it hangs yeah see that's
badass
that's like i wouldn't fight you in a
bar the guy with a fu manchu i figured
like punch you in the neck
or like reach into my chest and pull my
heart out because i'm watching it
beating his hand
actually you're probably right yeah i
don't know if i'd mess with a guy with a
food manchu i gotta be honest what does
my facial hair say about me
i think it says rugged yet handsome a
kitten could come by and lick that off
but i mean
you
it is a little thin man oh man so you've
actually made a movie
about being handsome and manly which is
being manson if you had to give me one
grooming tip
one one tip to preserve my sexy
um uh lotion the more you moisturize
your skin the younger you look for a
long time look at me who knew i was 75
can't even tell you hear that kids at
home lubricate
i think we're done let's check it out oh
yeah you're looking very mansom
yeah this is great thank you for
bringing me here thank you so much for
coming and uh i can't wait for the show
thank you all types of uh weird things
all types of sin magic yeah
seven weird ass yeah see like i'm
looking i'm feeling i'm feeling a little
feeling a little lust when i see that
yeah is that what you're feeling i'm
feeling a little pride
yeah i look at it yeah look at that guy
and maybe a little hubris
a little bit see i studied my doctor
my mom would be proud that's right see
you man cool thank you guys
now let's get some grub i know right i
know what you're thinking you're super
bummed out that this thing ended
the best thing you could do is subscribe
to the gq channel below and get in the
comments tell us who you think is manson
or who's the least mansomist of the
manson
let us know